on this episode I talk time time time
content content content and health
health health everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and you're watching the
askgaryvee show episode 21 fun fact
about the number 21 is most of you
really cared about turning 21 I didn't
give it a dro asks what's your best tip
for time management pijl actually I
don't know my tip for time management is
to have an assistant who you make the
Czar of your time and there's a let's go
find map tomato actually let's get it
let's get out of the cube a little bit
let's see if we can find DeMeo so for me
the time management is humanely scale
what I basically do is I find a human
being that allows me to do it and so in
this scenario that dude is my that's my
answer for time management putting human
being who actually is the Czar Matt
would you say you're the Czar of time ah
I might be a bit much but I'm good with
it and so you know he knocks on the
window and says your next meeting and he
texts me and he's like are you on this
call so that's what I do I use human
beings obviously using a human being to
manage your time it's not very practical
for most of the audience so I'm going to
try to give some practicality which is I
really don't know because prior to using
a human being I didn't really have a
great system obviously we have
technology now like phones that buzz you
and Google calendars I don't know how
people do it I just think it becomes a
religion I decided my time was worth a
lot to me and I created infrastructure
around it for me was humans for you it's
got to be something that reverse
engineers your actual behavior Dena me
asks why are you uploading the episodes
to Facebook instead of attaching a photo
linking to your website of the video or
using YouTube
the reason I'm posting this video in
face
book natively is because I fancy myself
as an expert or someone who at least
wants to be one day an expert and really
understanding things like you know what
the book was written about can you get
it back there Dirac Jab Jab Jab right
hook a lot of you read it you know that
I care about being Native being
platform-specific I am seeing data that
shows me that if I put the video in
natively and upload it versus linking it
to YouTube or my website about twenty to
thirty thousand more people see the
video I care about them seeing the video
I don't need to feel good about where my
traffic comes from I don't need the
vanity of having more YouTube views I
don't need to see my website getting
more traffic because I'm going to sell
ads on it I want people to hear the
answers to the questions I'm playing the
long game I want to bring value and the
more people that see it the more value
on providing if the feed natively is
going to allow me to reach more people
then that's what I'm gonna do hey Gary
how's it going it's dom gary that wanted
to say hello and ask you this as you
know i've talked to you about it before
i'm working on building an app with one
of my business partners and while I'm in
charge of adoption the app is probably
six months away from actually having a
working working prototype so what would
you suggest I start doing now to make
sure that I'm building it up so that
when it does come to adoption time and
the app is released we have plenty of
users that are going to be using it
thanks a lot Gary Tom first of all good
to see you thanks for your hard core
following ship over the last years years
and I can't quantify it but I know we've
been jamming hard for multiple years um
I'm gonna give you a really good answer
and this is the answer that's going to
work for everybody no matter whether you
have an app or you sell clocks content
content hunt clockwork huh
content content content content I think
you need to put up so let's say you're
putting out a fitness app or a
Productivity app for time management you
then need to create time management calm
which is not available but daily time
management calm or something and putting
out content around the genre you need to
create a content portal on medium or
your own blog or on rebel Mouse which I
believe in clearly link it up and and
you need to uh you need to basically
create content to get like-minded people
in that are you know you come out with
Fitness daily in yours is a fitness
utility app and then boom you've got
this audience and then when the app
comes out you pound them with it and it
comes out you need to gather people in a
place that are like-minded or most
likely to use the app and then when the
time's right shout to them jabbing and
then right hooking Gale asks if you
could teach everyone in the world one
thing you've learned what would it be ah
Daniel the two things I believe in the
most are empathy and gratitude but I
don't think that's quite teachable
self-awareness I don't think that this
is the best I don't think that's a
that's teachable I think the thing that
I've been taught the most through
experience that was intuitive but I
think is teachable is for everybody to
pay attention that the world is really
about depth not with right and so it's
you know do things that are meaningful
not wide you know I'm just a big
believer in this depth with game I watch
so much listen a lot of you guys know
this I answered this question two or
three episodes ago I'm paying attention
to you as much as you're paying
attention to me I might not be engaging
and replying on your posts or liking
your comments or all those things the
way you are with me because I'm doing it
at such a scale and I'm a busy mother
and like just you know even that extra
second is tough for me but so you see me
especially on Instagram I'm definitely
Harding up and replying and saying
thanks but a lot of you and this is why
I have so much passion for is you guys
are still in the tactics of width you're
looking for more likes and shares and
like a lot of right hook
and you've read all my books and you're
like yeah Gary you're right and then
you're not doing it and Here I am busier
than all of you
Here I am busier than all of you doing
this show providing depth engaging its
scale replying to your emails when they
come in trying to apply it scale on
Twitter
maybe not engaging with the consumption
of your content but definitely replying
to when you care and you want to be
heard by me and I'm going deep deep deep
while you shake your head when I talk
about deep but then you go out there and
you go wide Edward asks if you could go
back to your early 20s would you
prioritize help or was neglecting it
necessary to get where you are today
Edward great question I wanted to
address this one of the great things of
the show I keep saying is that I'm going
to answer questions I haven't been able
to answer and so thanks for all of you
of getting me to 21 um but the other
thing I get to do is clear up some
things so we're picking some questions I
think I sent this one to you Steve right
yeah we get to clarify on the show this
is the clarity our my friends we get to
clarify a little bit on this show and
what we are going to clarify is this I
bet you a lot of people are going to
think I'm going to go in one direction
but I'm going in another the answer is I
wish I prioritized my health I could
have slept one hour less I could have
what played one hour less of Settlers of
Catan with my brother back in the day I
could have worked there's some crazy one
I could have worked one less hour I
could have done a whole lot of things
but I should have found that one hour to
do what I've been doing for the last 65
days and prioritize my health so if I
could go back I'd be working out and
eating the way I'm doing it now all the
way back since then real quick I wasn't
joking leave more critiques
give me more feedback I love it I'm like
a teddy bear I want to hug my friends
thank you for allowing me to be in your
living room in your taxi or subway ride
with you on the phone or wherever you're
consuming this content this show is
really bringing back a little bit of a
blaze in my ass I don't know if that
means as it was coming out of my mouth
but like I'm excited to be like back in
this game that is a fun game for me for
a while
you know people have tweeted out like
Gary be doing what he does best I've
seen that come around a lot of times I
get pissed like best what's best as I
build businesses but there is some truth
that this seat feels awfully comfortable
to me and you guys commenting all you
people coming in and saying I just
caught this show last week I just found
out about you six days ago and I've
watched all 21 episodes I've been a
lurker and following you
I got am it you know what I call it it
is the oxygen that allows this show to
continue and I appreciate you
tremendously and so the question of the
day is very very very very very simple I
want your thoughts on the new iPhone
because some of you're going to have it
over this weekend and on the Alibaba IPO
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
that's a good call out to the fans
some people gonna have some real moments
there with themselves hey subscribe
it matters to me subscribe and did you
watch the last one and you better watch
the next one